[Musique]
donc à vélo on est bien évidemment tenu
de respecter les feux rouges comme tout
autre véhicule mais cependant il existe
une exception c'est ce petit panneau
l'aller qui en fait vous permet de
passer le feu rouge dans la direction
indiquée par la flèche par contre vous
êtes pas prioritaire donc s'il ya des
piétons aux deux voitures qui arrivent
vous devez laisser passer ce panneau
l'aï les carriers comme vous pouvez le
constater et il indique qu'il ya une
piste cyclable qui existe et que vous
pouvez l'entrée l'emprunter en revanche
hispano avait été circulaire serait
voulu dire que la piste cyclable est
obligatoire et que vous êtes tenu de
l'emprunter parce qu'on appelle les
double sens cyclable qui vous sont
indiquées par ce genre de panneau et les
petits pictogrammes sur le sol donc en
fait ces panneaux là en tant que
cycliste il vous autorise à prendre une
rue dans les deux sens certains
pourraient considérer ça comme dangereux
mais en théorie c'est quelque chose de
plutôt sécurisé puisque vous avez le
temps de voir l'autre véhicule arrive et
vous avez le temps d'anticiper le danger
tout comme l'automobiliste en théorie
s'il a les yeux sur la route depuis 1998
les cyclistes ont droit au stade vélo
donc cet espace dédié qu'on voit à côté
de moi qui en fait est sensé permettre
aux cyclistes déjà démarré en toute
sécurité devant les automobilistes au
feu rouge mais aussi de pouvoir se
déplacer sur la gauche de la voie s'ils
doivent tourner à gauche à
l'intersection
[Musique]
un des dangers les plus fréquents que
vous allez voir c'est les véhicules
garés sur votre piste cyclable à vélo
vous êtes tenu en théorie de tenir votre
droite sur la chaussée quand vous
déplacer mais il existe certains dangers
dans cette situation là comme par
exemple dans ce type de rues étroites
il existe le risque de ce qu'on appelle
la portière taj
c'est ta voix c'est-à-dire une portière
de voiture qui s'ouvre devant vous quand
elle est stationnée
heureusement il ya une loi qui vous
protège dans le code de la route qui
vous autorise à vous déplacer du bord
droit de la chaussée d'une distance
nécessaire à votre sécurité
en théorie une voiture elle me double à
un mètre de distance en ville et 1 mètre
orville ici mon bras y fait 80 cm
environ
donc vous voyez très clairement qu'une
voiture peut pas me déplacer entre me
dépasser en toute sécurité même si je me
sers complètement à droite il ya
malheureusement certains automobilistes
qui vont pas aimer ça du coup ils vont
essayer de vous mettre la pression de
vous klaxonner c'est pas grave c'est
votre droit vous avez le droit et dans
ces cas là et dans ces cas là vous avez
le droit de vous déplacer du bord droit
de la chaussée pour décourager tout
comportement dangereux ou illégal
pour les équipements recommandés on peut
parler du transport ou deux pour
transporter des choses sur un vélo moi
vous voyez personnellement j'utilise ce
type de sacoches mais vous pouvez avoir
un système de porte bagages à l'avant un
système de porte bagages à l'arrière ou
même des sacoches de cadres vraiment ça
ça va dépendre de votre usage moi
là-dedans jeu mais je peux mettre une
doudoune ou un k way ou un portable un
pantalon pour la pluie là aujourd'hui je
transporte un cadenas je transporte des
pneus pour un emmy award tout à l'heure
je n'ai cadenas avec un câble qui va
avec
donc moi ce que je recommande
personnellement quand cadenas sain et
solide tous les cadenas a priori peuvent
être cassée par les voleurs mais il ya
des cadenas qui vont dissuader des
voleurs et d'autres non ce type de
cadenas ça ça se coupe très rapidement
très facilement ça va pas sauver votre
vo ça il va falloir une cinquantaine de
secondes à une minute avant de pouvoir y
arriver donc vous vous en doutez c'est
évidemment bien plus safe
vous l'aurez constaté je porte pas de
casque le casque est obligatoire
seulement jusqu'à vos douze ans en
france il ya un débat éternel autour du
casque certains vous diront que vous
êtes complètement food roulait sans
casque
d'autres vous diront que ça peut être
plus dangereux de porter un casque comme
le monde certaines études
toujours est il que le casque est un
choix personnel selon votre confort et
votre aisance à vous déplacer à vélo
mais en aucun cas quelque chose
d'obligatoire
vous allez avoir de deux équipements
obligatoires principaux le premier c'est
la sonnette qui vous permettra
d'anticiper n'importe quel danger de
prévenir de votre arrivée et ensuite le
second équipement obligatoire c'est la
lumière une lumière blanche à l'avant
une lumière rouge à l'arrière
qu'ils soient fixes ou statique ensuite
avec la lumière il ya les catadioptres
qui sont également obligatoires sur un
vélo pour être bien visible de côté
[Musique]
si jamais vous vous déplacez à votre
travail à vélo vous pouvez bénéficier du
forfait mobilité durable qui est un peu
le parallèle du forfait kilométrique
offerts aux personnes qui se rendent au
travail en voiture
en fait ça vous permet d'avoir 400 euros
remboursés par votre employeur selon le
nombre de kilomètres que vous parcourez
parents à vélo pour entretenir vos vélos
ou pour acheter de l'équipement
supplémentaire
si vous mettez au vélo vous verrez assez
rapidement que c'est un des moyens les
plus rapides et plus fiables pour se
déplacer en ville tout d'abord parce que
vous êtes évidemment vous éviter les
bouchons
vous avez aujourd'hui maintenant un peu
de plus en plus en france
la chance d'avoir des itinéraires
cyclables sécurisées un des autres
avantages du vélo surtout en cette
période si particulière c'est bien
évidemment pour la santé outre la
possibilité de respecter les distances
entre nous c'est un des moindres
déplacements qui vous permet de faire
une activité physique quotidiennement
alors effectivement si vous comptez vous
mettre en selle bientôt vous allez vite
vous rend compte que vous avez
énormément d'options et de choix pour
acquérir votre premier vélo d'abord la
première question à se poser c'est
quelle va être votre usage quel va être
votre distance ou tout simplement sur
quoi vous vous sentez le plus
confortable après la deuxième question
c'est de savoir est ce que vous voulez
acheter votre premier vélo ouais si vous
voulez peut-être louer votre premier
vélo voir si ça vous plaît comme des
systèmes comme on a en île de france par
exemple ait délit go vous pouvez louer
un vélo électrique pour un prix très
réduits ensuite si vous vous lâchez
votre premier vélo si vous voulez
acheter un vélo neuf ou est ce que vous
voulez acheter un vélo d'occasion
alors ce qui est vraiment génial avec le
vélo c'est que peu importe votre budget
vous allez forcément trouver quelque
chose qui vous convient vous pouvez
trouver un vélo vraiment pas cher mais
de très bonne qualité en très bon état
pour 50 euros sur le bon coin vous
pouvez ensuite aller voir votre magasin
de vélos locales et discuté avec le
gérant de la meilleure option pour vous
selon votre budget vous pouvez trouver
aussi des vélos dans les grandes
enseignes de sport plus connus pour 200
300 euros après évidemment ça peut
monter beaucoup plus haut selon vos
envies et votre besoin
c'est vraiment moi ce que ce que j'aime
beaucoup avec le vélo c'est que peu
importe votre visage peu importe votre
csp peu importe votre budget peu importe
votre âge vous trouverez forcément un
vélo qui convient à votre usage à vos
besoins
[Musique]